ce téléphone a une caméra sur l'écran
regardez elle est planqué juste là et
hop je souhaite il y a plus de caméra et
en fait ce qui est super intéressant
c'est la très grosse densité de pixel
qu'on y retrouve ici on peut regarder
également sur une autre application on
la voit quasiment pas ce smartphone
c'est un smartphone de ZTE et ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que ça fait
un moment qui développe cette
technologie de caméra sur l'écran et en
plus je vous montre regardez elle est
située juste ici c'est quand même pas
mal vous voyez au niveau des images hop
là je fais une photo bon c'est pas
dégueu après il y a un algo qui va venir
récupérer qui va venir corriger tout ça
et lorsque vous passez d'un côté et de
l'autre il vient se dessiner légèrement
avec un petit liseré en haut qui est là
et lorsque vous soyez comme ça et bien
ça a totalement disparu le smartphone
c'est le ZTE axone 40 ultra édition
limitée ici je suis pas sûr que le reste
de la configuration sera nécessairement
extrêmement intéressant pour vous mais
cette technologie est là la technologie
évolue et le boulot que fait ZTE au
niveau de la densité de pixel pour la
caméra sur l'écran c'est quand même
vachement bien alors cette technologie
on la trouve notamment chez Samsung sur
le Galaxy Z fold 4 et Z fold 2 3 qui est
aussi bien et qui va pas aussi loin que
ce que nous propose ztei est-ce que vous
avez déjà vu cette technologie de caméra
sous l'écran et est-ce que ça pourrait
vous intéresser bien évidemment vous
marquez tout ça dans les commentaires